this is a production of Cornell
University
today really lovely introduction
um I'd like to start out with some thank
yous of my own big thank you to my
committee Matt Lloyd drinkwater and
Harold
you guys have been wise and pragmatic
and encouraging and supportive and it's
really helped me shape my research
um
also a huge thank you to my lab the
sustainable cropping systems lab
seriously could have not couldn't have
done it without you all and I'm so
grateful and appreciative that we work
so well together as a team it's really
it's it's so much fun to go to work
every day
um a big thank you to Jerry cherny who
helped with 4-H quality Stephen mursky
my USDA collaborator Paul and Mike out
at the farm Dave Wilson from King's
aggregate who helped select uh seeds for
me big thank you to Sonam and to the
grad students within the department
and other plant science departments
um
so just a really straightforward
background some an outline of how the
presentation will go with some
background information some methods and
then the results section which I'll be
presenting in two parts one is crop
performance so a little bit about crop
production and the other one is more
applied so some of the benefits and
trade-offs of the different seed
treatments I use and then we'll do a
summary and then I'll tell you about
some future plans I have uh I couldn't
see this but I will be doing a PhD with
Matt I couldn't imagine leaving the lab
you know this winter anything so
um
just to start off with this is a graph
that describes the trend in dairy farms
distribution so on uh it's the number of
farms over time is declining and the
average Farm size is growing to me this
trend is very disturbing it's not just
for dairy farm it's true in other Ag
Systems
but particularly within dairy farms
there's been this huge decline 200 Farms
with less than 200 cows have the farm
size has decreased between 2000 2006 by
30 so that's really huge this trend is
is predicted to increase there are a lot
of structural differences that come with
Farm sizes and probably the biggest
takeaway of that for this presentation
is that smaller Farms smaller dairy
farms tend to grow more at their own
feed
this is a map that describes forage
projection in the United States so for
those who aren't familiar forage is the
edible plant part that isn't separated
the grain is not separated and the
forages are then fed chick raising
animals so cows sheep goats but in this
case mostly cows New York is a huge
producer of forage
third largest producer of corn silage
Alfalfa and Timothy also up there and
most of those forages go into Dairy
production and New York is the third
largest producer of milk in the country
this is a picture of the 2012 drought in
August I started grad school when at
this time so I started when this drought
was happening and when I was actually
studying agriculture for the first time
and it was it was very influential for
when my research eventually came to be
but it was also like a
it was huge it happened in the states
and 80 percent of of agricultural land
was affected 75 of corn and soybean
production were severely or greater
affected by the drought mostly in the
Heartland here but also you can see that
New York State up here it has some
different colors it was affected by the
drought and it was it was this that that
kind of took my research in a way uh on
a certain path and it was very emotional
for people I think we would drive past
and we would see the corn that was just
very stunted or we would see Farmers
standing in their fields just looking
lost and and and desolate they had no
idea what they could do and so one of
the options Farmers have is that they
could plant these summer annual forage
intercrops so typically right now
they're mostly known as these emergency
forages and they're planted after corn
failure but they also fit into the small
green system
so that's sometimes known as triple
cropping and that's when you have a
winter cereal and it's coming out so you
know like after traditionally or after
wheat and then you plant these things in
the middle of the summer and then the
growing season is short enough that you
can get them out in time to really
establish another cereal crop another
grain crop into the winter so you can
plant these between the middle of June
in the middle of July they're pretty
fast growing you can get a forage cut
between 35 45 days
um seeds reach maturity around 90 days
and the species I've selected for this
presentation for the research these are
drought tolerant and in general require
fewer inputs than corn silage
there's some very basic benefits for
inner cropping one you're decreasing the
risk by planting multiple species so by
having different species that react
differently that use the resources
differently you're spreading out that
risk and you're really tapping into the
functional diversity of the plants this
in turn increases the resilience of the
ecosystem and it strengthens it because
you really are depending on the species
that are there and the things that come
with it by changing the pasture or weed
pressure on
changing the microbial communities of
the soil and instead of relying on these
external inputs which I think are is
quite a fragile system and so this is
also Pearson causes the regenerative
semi-close
uh agriculture so it's when the
nutrients are kind of coming off of the
farm and then if you have a dairy
production that when you were staying on
the farm so if you think about it in
terms of where the nutrients are going
it's a more closed structure than if
you're exporting nutrients to and from
uh this is a
so some related summer annual intercrops
I think there's a growing interest among
farmers and certainly the nrcs has been
promoting the summer annual intercrops
as cover crop cocktails and mixtures
this is Ray Archuleta from the nrcs
um I think we should make a motivational
poster of this for the lab is this is
this nrcs guy directing us to plant a
summer annual intercrops uh there's been
research done by Kevin Armstrong in 2008
they were comparing grass flaking
mixtures for forage quality for
um with corn silage and and they tested
out some different legumes and they said
that the loblobin
increased the forage quality because
you're in you're increasing the crude
protein but you're not decreasing the
yield so that's pretty key for Farmers
you don't want to take a yield cut uh
Dan Brainerd also did some research with
Robin belinder regarding grass legging
mixtures they chose two grasses and two
legumes and the best combination they
found was a cow pee with Millet which
improved noduation it lowered the seed
costs because the grains are this
expensive than the legumes and also you
they managed to reduce the weed seed
Productions and if they were planting
the cow pea separately
so some considerations with inner
cropping I find intercopying experiments
they're very challenging because they
get so big so fast because you're like
what species should I look at oh and I
should look at also I should look at the
seating rate and all of a sudden you
have like 500 different treatments and
then your committee says
probably shouldn't have 500 different
achievements
um so species selection is very
important and even within species
different cultivar selection is
important the seeding rates you choose
and then the ratio of those seeding
rates to the other species as well as
the soil fertility so you know depending
on your your
your uh like your playing field where
you're starting off with really
um
what am I trying to say it really
affects the crop production later on so
if you have very fertile soil then
perhaps the grasses would do better but
if you have more legumes and less
fertile soil then the leggings would do
better
so just to summarize my entire two and a
half years here uh in one slide I'm
testing the ecological Theory and
quantifying potential benefits from
inner cropping and I'm doing this within
an alternative warm season drought
tolerant functionally diverse cropping
mixture in the Northeast and in the
Mid-Atlantic and I'm also so these two
points these are like a little more
theoretical but I'm very much interested
in how does this knowledge apply to
Farmers how can people use this
information and so I really want to
quantify the trade-offs between forage
quality and yield and determine optimal
management I really would like to tell
farmers at the end I've tested this and
I think this is the best mixture or the
best thing you can do in your situation
so I have two main research questions
the first is how do crops the reform and
are there even benefits to Inner
cropping and the second research
question is what are the trade-offs
between yield and forage quality over
time
free PC selection I chose four species
and I based it off of two different
functional traits so nitrogen fixing
ability whether a plant is a grass or
legume and also plant architecture so
the stature of the plant whether it's
bushy or taller and so for the two
grasses I chose a hybrid Pearl Millet
and it's abbreviated with an m and it's
throughout the presentation
and it's the shorter variety of millet
used for 4-H and then for the Tall Grass
I use sorghum Sudan grass the BMR
variety it's a cross between sorghum and
sorghum Sudanese grass and it looks very
similar to Corn it grows quite tall
with the two legumes I use cow pee in
the sauce we call them black-eyed peas
they're abbreviated with the c and then
Sun hemp uh in San hemp is abbreviated
with an H in Sun hemp I think is the
least Familiar of these crops to this
audience is native to India it's this
fiber and forage crop that they grow
there and it's and it's tall it goes
quite tall and it's very beautiful and
it the leaves in the stem are iridescent
um
so I had two growing Seasons a 2013 and
2014 and three different field sites we
were at Beltsville Maryland the USDA
headquarters uh and then Aurora New York
which is about 40 miles away from here
and then our most northern site was in
willsboro New York and so that was in
the middle of that Adirondacks next to
Vermont and we had a different number of
fields so if there was times two then we
had two fields at that field site we
planted between the middle of June to
the middle of July we had four to six
reps per site
the experiment design we prepped the
seed beds this is Chris on our on our
tractor so we prep the seabeds plowed
just cultipact we applied 35 kilograms
per hectare of nitrogen in the form of
poultry litter and 35 kilograms is half
the recommended amount as sorghum
sedan grass and the idea for for doing
it like that is that if we fertilize at
the full recommendation then we're
really shifting that fertility that
competition over to the grasses which
are able to use that nitrogen more
efficiently than the legumes and then if
we didn't fertilize it all we're afraid
we would shift the competition too much
to the legumes and so we split the
difference and decided 35 was was a good
number uh no pesticides or herbicides
were applied I think that's pretty
typical for a forage system but
this is low input so I would like to
emphasize that and seeds were drilled to
four centimeters down and plot signs it
plot sizes range from 9 to 40 meters
squared this was a single cut so in some
forages you can take multiple Cuts over
time and then you take cuts of the
regrowth but because we're using a
mixture of species they have different
maternity dates different regrowth rates
we just did a single cut system that was
also a way to keep the number of the
number of samplings down into the
pragmatic sphere
uh proceed treatment so we have the four
species in monoculture and these are
their seeding rates here in this middle
column and again the abbreviations and
then the cost per hectare of those
um seeds and then we tested four three
species mixtures and they're indicated
with an X and then we have their cost
per hectare and of course the one
possible for a species mixture
been seating uh the seating rates were
for the three species mixture each
species was seated at one third of its
rate in monoculture so if you're looking
at Millet in a three CC's mixture 21
divided by three so you're seating at
seven kilograms per hectare and then for
the fourth species rate you're seating
at one quarter of its monoculture rate
and there was a randomized complete
block design
a different sampling methods so uh we
took crop density crop biomass and weed
biomass we essentially obeyed a half
meter Square quadrat down and we clipped
at 10 centimeters above the soil this
was to simulate a forage cut where
they're not going to be clipping right
at the soil level but a little bit above
and then crossword separated out by
species and then uh dried and then later
weighed
we had two sampling dates in 2013 45
days and 90 days after planting and in
2014 we added an additional sampling
date at 35 days and so that was to the
purpose of that was to really get to the
to the forage quality question how does
forage quality change over 35 and 45
days which is kind of The Sweet Spot
in addition to the biomass sampling we
also took light Transmissions to assess
the canopy cover we did that by a
sliding a line sensor underneath the
canopy and then having a holding a
pointerest point sensor above the canopy
and then taking simultaneous
measurements and that was to capture how
much light was passing through the
canopy and also we did take some soil
samples to understand the Baseline
fertility of the soil that we were
working in
free data analysis for this presentation
I'll be talking to you about the 45 days
pulled across sites in years there
weren't major site differences all the
orders of the treatment were pretty
similar across all the sites there were
really big year differences
um I don't know if you all noticed but
2014 was quite a bit colder than 2013
for the summer so the biomass production
in 2014 was almost half of that in 2013.
uh to analyze the data we did an
analysis I did an analysis of variance
with treatment as effective fixed effect
and gear block and location were
considered random effects and then I
used a two key tests to show the
differences between the means
so this is the results section part one
the crop performance part
and this is a couple of shots of us in
the field this is last year at Aurora
about a month after planting and the
letters here indicate the seeding
treatments so you can see the cowpea and
monoculture the canopy really hadn't
closed especially if you look at the
four species mixture and then two months
later you see here the Millet and the
sun hemp were planted in monoculture
they're looking very full and nice but
when you look at the species mixtures
they just have so much texture they just
look like they're taking up so much more
space
this is data for the 45 days after
planting pools across sites and years
and this is the total biomass and down
at the bottom we have the four species
in monoculture the four three species
mixtures and then the 1 4 species
mixture and then the crop by 11
kilograms per hectare on the y-axis
and you can see that the legumes in
monoculture did not really do that well
the grasses
we're very similar and very similar to
the mixtures with Millet sorghum Sun
hemp producing the highest amount of
biomass and then the story gum Sun hemp
copy producing the lowest amount of
biomass in the mixtures
this is a graph the same one you saw
before it except now you can see the
composition of the mixtures and so each
color stands for a monoculture and then
here you can see a lot of purple and
green and those are the the grasses and
they make up quite a bit of that crop
biomass
dominant weeds we had quite a we had
some issues with volunteer crops
depending on our field sites so at one
site in willsboro we went in after a
canola variety trial and there was a lot
of canola but so it was like very
terrible because we considered it weed
biomass in reality though that stuff
makes great forage so it was Mike kept
trying to convince me oh you should run
the the forage quality analysis with the
weed biomass and I was like yes I would
love to do that because like we know
this would be so much higher
um we also had some issues with some
volunteer wheat uh so at Aurora we had a
later planting date and I think Paul was
driving his tractor driving the combine
off the field as Chris was driving uh
the tractor onto the field to prepare
the weed seed bed so any uh wheat that
that didn't make it onto the combine had
a very nice weed seed bed to grow into
but again it made it first and it would
probably make for some decent forage
quality another field we had in this an
issue with mustard I'll talk a little
bit more about that in a second and then
pretty much the usual suspects of Summer
annual
um weeds Ragweed pigweed lamb's quarter
so here we have a weird phytometer and
this mustard in bloom was beautiful it
was it really was beautiful and and it
was great also overseeing the treatment
differences so you can just look here
and I've divided these fields uh this
field by the different treatments you
can see the mixture that contained the
Sorghum was very good at at
um out competing the mustard but this
very dark yellow lots of yellow down in
this corner this was a cow peeing
monoculture so it really you could just
tell the difference of how competitive
some species in some mixtures were
this graph shows a crop biomass in the
brown and the weed biomass in the yellow
bars on top so you can see that the
legume monocultures produce
the most weeds grasses were not very
weedy some of the mixtures didn't have
that many weeds they were all a little
similar though and as terrible as the
cowpea and Sun hemp where it's
suppressing weeds they certainly did a
good job more than they could have in
2014 we had a control plot we put
control plots in all of our Fields you
can really tell
um
like
like how how much less weeds there are
um even when just something was planted
so in addition to the crop production
and the crop biomass and the weed
biomass also doing some additional
metrics land equivalent ratio which
measures the efficiency of mixtures
relative to monocultures the crop growth
rate would just shows the change in
biomass over the change in time and also
species evenness by biomass which shows
the relative production measures the
relative production and species
dominance and so these are all like
three kind of snapshots of how these
mixtures performed and how the species
within the mixtures performed
the first one land equivalent ratio it
is the sum of the ratios of inner crop
yield for a species divided by the
monoculture yield I've tried to depict
it in this cartoon here so uh in the
inner crop you can see that all the
species grow better than when they're
planted separately in monoculture and
this is due to less intra-specific
competition so Liars that are greater
than one describe when intercops are
more efficient than monocultures
and very exciting we all the mixtures
that were planted for this experiment
had lures that were greater than one so
all of these mixtures were more
efficient
than we're more efficient in terms of
biomass production per space than if
this species had been separated out
implanted in monoculture
this is crab growth rate measured in
kilograms per hectare per day and here
we have two columns for the grasses and
two columns for the legumes and I showed
the slope up here you can see the crop
growth tweets for the grasses in
monoculture are really high so it shows
like a much steeper slope than the
legumes which have a lower crop growth
rate and they have a smaller slope so I
just want to walk you through this one
Millet growth rate when it was in
monoculture it was about 17 kilograms
per hectare per day and then when it was
planted in these mixtures it
decreased in this mixture it didn't
decrease significantly so the growth
rate in when it was planted with the sun
hemp and the copy was similar to that as
if it were planted in monoculture and
the other growth rates decreased a half
maybe a third a similar Trend you see
with sore government has a very high
crop growth rate when it was in
monoculture and it falls
when it is planted in mixture so
remember you're also seating at like one
third to a quarter of the
uh monoculture rate the legumes are a
little bit of a sadder story
um so their crop growth rate in
monoculture were lower just in general
than the grasses like so these plants
characteristics just have a slower
growth rate and when they were planted
with mixtures uh it just got romped a
little
um cow pea fell by a decrease the crop
grocery decreased by an order of
magnitude and so it was
really
um facing a lot of competition when it
was intercropped
so the third snapshot the third
additional metric I want to describe to
you is species evenness and usually
species evenness is done with plant
density we thought that doing it by
biomass was a little bit more revealing
uh here we see low evenness in this
cartoon and you can see that the sun's
the one species is much bigger than the
other species and then a high evenness
means that you know the plants grow
similarly well so species even this is a
metric that goes from zero to one and
the blue bars here indicate the evenness
at 45 days in the brown bars or even
this at 90 days and so we see that
military gum Sun hemp it was the most
even species at 45 days and also the
most even at 90 days and that just says
those three species when they're planted
together if you think of them as a team
each teammate is holding its own weight
a little bit more than if you had
sorghum Sun hemp and cowpea you can just
imagine that cow pee was dominating it
was gonna it like its growth definitely
was much greater than the sun hemp and
the cow pea
uh just in general
species evenness decreased over time so
so
as the growing season went on there was
a decrease as one species became more
dominant than other species in some of
these mixtures
so it is summarize this part of the
results section mixture is produced a
similar amount of biomass as grass
monocultures
there is over yielding seen by all the
mixtures indicated by an elyr greater
than one
and there is a higher crop growth rate
in general in the monocultures except
for millet with sun hemp and cowpea
mixtures with two grasses tended to be
more even and mixtures with two leggings
tended to be less even and there is a
decrease in evenness over time
so now I want to switch to the more
applied findings the different
um the second results section
and this goes back to the question what
are the what are the trade-offs between
yields and forage quality over time and
so it's a very short primer on forage
quality a forged quality tends to
decrease
over time as the plants get larger while
the yield tends to increase
and so
that that reason uh we'll see is because
when the plants are younger they have a
lower fiber content that fiber content
means the animal can consume more of
that diet and also it's it's higher
energy because it's full of these the
cell content through full of these
nutritious digestible like quickly
digestible things sugars proteins as the
plant ages there's an increase in these
structural carbohydrates that make up
the cell wall particularly Hemi
cellulose and cellulose and so when it's
a high fiber diet when the when the
plant is older then they
then there's a lower intake by The
Animals because they feel
um Fuller
they they have more fiber when they're
when they're eating that and because
they can't cannot consume as much there
is a lower energy uh just in general of
the diet
so this is relative feed value at 35
days uh in 2014
and relative feed value is this metric
between digestibility and fiber content
and it was used by the industry for a
very long time before it became
affordable to test for the protein
content I was not able to get the
protein analysis done in time for this
presentation so I'm using this metric
even though it only tells part of the
story because it doesn't require any
protein content the relative feed value
it's um
relative feed values this metric that
that's based off of forage legumes and
it tells you gives you this one number
of how good or not a forage is and so we
can see the relative feed value is quite
high for the legumes and this metric
tends to over uh to underestimate forage
quality for grasses so that's the reason
it's not used as much anymore and so the
grasses in monoculture are quite low
then we have these mixtures the military
sorghum or sorry the military
has the highest forage quality of all
the mixtures and the other mixtures
perform similarly well
um these yellow bars here indicate what
kind of feed you would like to give to a
cow the brighter yellow is what you
would the kind of quality of feed you
would give to a lactating cow and the
less yellow the Browner bar is feet
that's still good enough but maybe not
as much energy that you would give to a
cow that is producing milk
so you can see that uh most
mostly except for this tournament just
by a little bit all fit into this range
that it's safe to feed uh and even good
to feed for lactating cows and again
this metric really underestimates the
forage quality of the grasses
this next part uh this next graph really
tries to answer the question of what are
the trade-offs between yields and the
forage quality and so the way the best
way to do this metric was just to
multiply the relative feed value by the
yield so we know that the grasses had a
very high yield compared to the legumes
but we also know that the grasses didn't
have that great of a forage quality and
here we see these big differences so the
purple bars are the first harvest at 35
days and then the green are 45 days and
the Blue 90 days we see some really nice
High
um
High bars for these legumes when they're
in monoculture and that falls and part
of its flowing is due to a decrease in
forage quality over time but part of it
is also to the fact that they don't
yield quite as much as the motor the
Sorghum so you have yield that's really
pushing up These Bars here
I didn't want to overwhelm you all with
with the all the bars all at once but
here are the different mixtures you can
see that the Millet Sun hemp coffee had
the highest forage quality for the
mixture it falls
um and then yield really takes over for
some of the yields is making up the
difference in the bar sizes for some of
these other mixtures
so just in general I want to summarize
that there were a lot of sight year
differences for forage quality
Forest quality decreased over time
optimal Harvest for the grasses and the
mixtures using the relative feed value
metric was at 35 days
um leggings contain less fiber and work
more digestible and grasses in
monoculture had a higher fiber content
and because most of the mixtures the
majority of that mixture the biomass of
that mixture was
um grasses the mixtures also had quite a
high fiber content as well
here I would like to touch on the
economics I'm really excited to develop
some of these ideas more but
but here we have the cost per hectare
that we saw at the beginning for the
seeds for the different seed treatments
we have 35 days 45 days and 90 days
production per dollar so that's
kilograms per dollar
and you can see really that Millet has
this very low seating cost per hectare
and this is for a couple of different
reasons one
but related reasons
um the costume really is so much lower
is because the seeding rate in general
is so much slower it was 21 versus 60 or
80 for some of the others
and the seeds for millet are quite a bit
smaller than some of the other seed
treatments so you can plant less of it
it's less expensive
and it's really it's really driving the
trend here for the in the production per
dollar this is also seen here with the
Millet sorghum Sun hemp produced the
most and it had the highest production
per dollar
uh I think one of the challenges that
I've seen when doing this research is
that the seed cost to me seem pretty
prohibitive for Farmers to actually do
but I think part of that is because of
the seed economies of scale so if more
people adopted this practice it would
drive down the price that you would have
more suppliers entering the the market
and producing varieties that you know
are high yielding for this region at a
lower cost
uh and also forgot to mention this the
fourth species mixture came out right in
the middle between all the three species
mixtures
um so some final recommendations uh we
looked at a lot of different metrics we
looked at yield we looked at weed
biomass weed suppression and we looked
at the forage quality we touched on the
cost so there are a lot of different
factors in play as to what I would
recommend Farmers to do
um just to summarize Millet had the
greatest production It produced the most
biomass and it was the lower cost by far
military sorghum send him mixture had
the greatest production of a mixture and
it also had the lowest cost per mixture
at a really high ler and a really high
evenness that I was saying you know the
sun hemp wasn't being completely
dominated by the Millet or the Sorghum
and the rfv uh the relative feed value
was near that threshold for lactating
cows it was the highest producing
perhaps with a better forage quality
metric it would put it into that range
of being a good forage quality
the million Sun hemp cow pea mixture had
the greatest forage quality was also the
least most weird suppressive uh and in
that mixture the Millet had the same
growth rate as it did in monoculture so
you're not taking a yield loss if you
were to just if you were going to have
the mindset of planting a grass with
some additional legumes you weren't
taking a a yield Blaster but it had a
little bit of a higher production cost
um to close I just want to talk a little
bit about some of my PhD work that's
also had two growing seasons and maybe
some of you were wondering what about
those bicultures well don't worry
they're coming
um so for this work for these
experiments which are also called safe
the summer animal forage experiments I'm
looking at monoculture rates so that
that recommended seeding rate and how it
changes and if you're planting how the
biomass changes at 70 of the seating
rate or 90 of this heating rate and also
looking at all the bicultural
combinations so there are four species
there are six possible biculture
combinations and more than that more
than just looking at like 50 50 of
millet and sorghum and 50 50 of millet
and Sun hemp I'm really
um
I'm really looking at different seating
rate ratios so like 20 percent Millet
and then like 60
sorghum and doing that for all six
combinations of bicultures to really
understand what are what are the
Dynamics within the seeding rate ratios
and how does that relate to the
recommended seeding rates of these
species in monoculture
and so then I would like I will be doing
some modeling of the competition between
the inner crops really getting an
interest specific competition and
inter-specific competition
um and finally for for some other future
work
I'm gonna be doing some farmer
interviews understanding metrics I'm I'm
really interested in understanding the
metrics for behavior
um change in terms of agricultural
production so what policies need to be
there that would influence farmer
decision making what barriers cannot be
there
I think this is incredibly important and
it's something I'm very interested in
it's in that that expansion stage of a
PhD where you're saying yes and this and
yes and this and it hasn't been
condensed yet but in general I'm so
interested in science communication the
relationship and the communication
between uh scientists and farmers and
scientists in the general public I'm
also interested in agricultural policy
potentially
after a PhD may be going to Washington
um
so with that I will take some time for
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu